all right welcome back a little new idea
for you here when this one applies to
learning and as most certainly would
threaten to turn our current educational
system on its head what's unclear is
whether it's good for America a
California school called the Khan
Academy is reinventing traditional
teaching by giving students lectures
that they can watch at home on their own
time rewatch them if they like and then
having them do the homework when they're
in school in the classroom
by removing the one size fits all
lecture from the classroom and letting
and letting students have a self-paced
lecture at home and then when you go to
the classroom letting them do work
having the student to teacher walk
around having the peers actually be able
to interact with each other these
teachers have used technology to
humanize the classroom well the founder
Salman Khan started out by posting
lessons for his cousin on YouTube and
now the Khan Academy has over a million
unique students per month and boasts
more than 2,000 tutorials covering
everything from basic addition and
subtraction to advanced calculus physics
and chemistry and joining us now has
been gold Hirsch the CEO of good it's a
company dedicated to moving the world
forward through its website magazine
videos and events he thought that Khan
was one of the breakout stars at this
year's technology and entertainment and
Design Conference and before we get to
all this Khan Academy a business Ben do
you like it better when we're on
opposite coasts or would you be
comfortable if I was to move out to
California to spend more time with you
I'd love to have you out here doing I
think we do we do better in person and
do you feel that you speak on behalf of
the entire Southern California community
when you welcomed me into that universe
the thoughtful ones okay so you know we
all get into how many thoughtful ones
there are but we will get into this why
did you decide to feature this so
prominently with good you know for the
past two years good and University of
Phoenix have been focus on focusing on
solutions in this education space and we
haven't seen anything like it and to
contextualize the findings for you look
at Los Angeles we have Teach for America
we have City Year we have
cap Academy the best of the best of
social innovators but they're facing a
serious problem 600,000 students in
LAUSD with a 50 percent graduation rate
that's terrifying and the bottom line is
the solutions that we have on the ground
in my opinion aren't going to catch this
problem we need a disruptive technology
we need to really revolutionize how
we're tackling this Khan Academy is the
first thing I've seen that gives me
confidence that we're going to tackle it
it's the most exciting thing I've seen
that we're gonna we're gonna do this so
I'm pleased to bring it to your show I
think we're gonna dig into a good
conversation alright let's have at it
the man behind the ideas joins us all
man Khan founder of the Khan Academy
high praise for what you've got going
from our friend been down there in
Southern California he's a thoughtful
Southern Californian is how he likes to
refer to himself what have you found is
the biggest problem with this what is
the greatest barrier the greatest
resistance point to this well I think
it's it's as well as it's a radical
change to what traditionally happens in
a classroom and if you're telling
someone to do a homework in the
classroom it's not called homework
anymore but but I think once teachers
and students get used to it it's kind of
like they they start to think about what
they what they even did before you know
probably the biggest problem is well I
wouldn't call it a problem it's actually
a great thing in the same classrooms we
have a fit we have a pilot over here in
Northern California where you have a 5th
grade classroom this is their math
curriculum and that same 5th grade
classroom there are some kids doing 3rd
grade math and there some kids doing
trigonometry and the teacher needs to
feel comfortable with that but what's
cool about is that they're getting a
dashboard they see where everyone is and
and and every student can work at their
own pace if you were to look been at the
problem of having different same age but
at different places right that's the
whole thing with this sort of the
educational system is you got one kid
doing trigonometry and other and another
one who's trailing behind how do you see
this what did you see about this that
you felt not only addressed the dropout
rate but addressed the the variability
and though how people learn I mean if
you look at decreasing budgets and
increasing class sizes we need to solve
the efficiency problem and teachers time
is a limited amount so having this
technology where they can evaluate on a
person-by-person basis
where their kids are at and they can
have their classroom time to work with
their kids who are at different levels
directly so they can be taking the
lectures at home through Khan Academy
that's a big solution to a critical
problem solving walk me through very
briefly how this works let's say I've
gotten a couple of kids there they're in
a traditional environment I want to
intrude by what you're saying how would
it work so every student works at their
own pace they literally do exercise at
their own pace they start 1+1 and they
keep moving up all the way through
algebra or trigonometry however far they
want to go they have trouble with
anything the videos are there they can
actually watch them at home or or in
class time and the teacher when they
come to class they don't give lectures
they don't grade homework they don't
give exams they literally just get a
dashboard they see where every kid in
the in the class is and some kids may be
ahead some kids might be behind and we
actually see them flipping around some
of the kids that were behind race ahead
later on and all the teacher does is
look at the kids who are stuck look at
the kids where the video and the
software isn't enough for them to get
past that problem and and then the
teacher just intervenes on those kids
are even better gets one of the kids
that are already proficient on that
module because they have all of the data
to actually tutor their peers and so you
can have a class where everyone's
working at their own you say that
instead of penalizing failure and
rewarding test-taking ability like our
current system does right now
education should encourage failure and
experimentation but demand mastery why
do you think this model achieves that
well what we do is we force you know in
a traditional model I'll give you some
lectures homework lectures homework and
then we have a snapshot exam and
regardless of whether you get a 70 or 80
or 90% on that exam we move on to the
next concept and no one ever asked what
was that 10% you didn't know and so what
we see happening in our school system is
by the time people get to eighth or
ninth grade they're taking algebra
they're smart kids they have a great
algebra teacher but they're still
flunking algebra because they have these
that 10% gap from 5th grade math that
15% graph gap from 4th grade math so the
way we're doing it is we're actually
teaching math the way you would teach
anything else if you if you learn to
ride a bicycle you would stay on that
bicycle until you master the bicycle
before you try a motorcycle or a
unicycle or anything more advanced so
what we're doing is we're making sure
every kid has all of their gaps filled
so they literally started
plus one equals two and they don't move
on until they have a hundred percent
mass very quickly Ben what do you see is
the barrier to scaling this I think it's
money you know getting the getting Khan
Academy the resources they need to fill
out their programming and then getting
school districts to adopt a pretty
innovative solution I think teachers are
gonna want this it's gonna help them do
their job and I think given what we're
facing as I said 50% of a 600,000 person
school district is looking to not
graduate from high school there are more
jobs for high school dropouts right now
like this must be adopted yep listen I
wholeheartedly agree and I thank you Ben
gold Hirsch as America's thoughtful
Southern Californian for bringing that
to our attention and Sulman it's a true
pleasure to meet you congratulations on
what you've achieved up to this point
and do let us know what we can help you
with in the future check out all of it
of course on Goods web